un desacuerdo territorial con más de un
siglo de existencia continúa sobre la
mesa de la justicia internacional el
máximo órgano judicial de las Naciones
Unidas Se declaró con jurisdicción en el
diferendo limítrofe que sostienen
Venezuela y Guyana el espacio en disputa
es abundante en petróleo gas y otros
minerales representa el 70% del
territorio cuyanés Georgetown aplaudió
el anuncio
todos los estados miembros de las
Naciones Unidas incluidos Guyana y
Venezuela están obligados en virtud de
la carta de las Naciones Unidas a
cumplir con las sentencias vinculantes
de la corte sin embargo Venezuela no
reconoce el rol de la Corte
Internacional de Justicia que la
República bolivariana de Venezuela no
reconoce el mecanismo judicial como
medio de resolución de la mencionada
controversia por cuanto excluye la
naturaleza y objeto de este acuerdo
Rodríguez se refiere al pacto firmado
con el Reino Unido en 1966 que establece
los a seguir para la resolución del
conflicto Caracas arguye que la
discusión es con el reino inglés
Seguiremos la lucha incansable y firme
por defender el respeto al histórico
acuerdo de Ginebra y la territorialidad
de nuestra digna nación
Guyana que en la década de los 60 no
había alcanzado su independencia de
Londres rechaces argumento sobre una
sentencia de 1899 que ya había
establecido los límites actuales el
origen del caso en la corte mundial Data
de 2018 cuando una representación
guyanesa pidió el alto tribunal que
ratificara los bordes establecidos en
París